[موسيقى]
صباح الخير
لسهام ولا نادين وصباح الخير لكل
المشاهدين طبعا اييه تاخر علينا العم حسن
اليوم على غير العادي اييه هو بشتغل في
مهنه الحداد العربيه خلينا نفهم منه شو
الفرق بين الحداد العاديه والحداد العربيه
عم حسن صباح الخير صباح النور اكل سنه لك
في هاي المهني
سبع سنين
شايف حاجه في كثير زيك حدادين هون
غيرك انت الله يعطيك الصحه وطوله العمر
يعني نادين وسهام غالبا في هاي المشاغل او
الحداد العربيه بتهتم بالادوات الزراعيه
التقليديه
مع الخيل
عندك هنا النار ولا المطرقه ولا ايه
اه اللي بدق كل الحجر
[موسيقى]
الله يعطيك الصحه ويعطيك العافيه طبعا
نعيد بس الادوات الزراعيه القديمه
عود الحراث اللي كان يستخدم على الدوام
يتم تسديده بشكل دوري كل الموسم الزراعي
هون
[موسيقى]
بتعمل ايه في الابواب الكبديك مهان
عنا بروح اشتري من عند الخيار هذا ابو
نادر الخليلي
اشتغل
عم حسن شكرا لك
تندر مش بس في الاراضي الفلسطينيه ربما في
الوطن العربي بشكل عام العمل بالحداده
اليدويه ما كان في وقت نورجيكم انه بس
تسخين الحديد هون في هذا المكان يتم اشعال
النار وتسخين الحديد ويتم تركوا على هذه
المطرقه
احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر خالد ونشكر ضيفك
الحاج حسن على هذه الفقره وتعرفنا فيها
اكثر على تاريخ الحداده العربيه التي
تعتبر من اقدم المهن شكرا لكم